you can easily find the area of a
triangle when given its base and height
but what if you're only given the
lengths of its sides let's say a B and C
how do we find the area of this triangle
we have a formula for it the area equals
the square root of s times s minus a
times s minus B times s minus C a B and
C are the length of the triangle but
what on earth is s it is the semi
perimeter of the triangle S will equal a
plus B plus C by 2 that is the perimeter
divided by 2 or half the perimeter
here's a typical problem that you may
come across in your exams we are given a
triangle with lengths 5 12 and 13 units
and are asked to find its area as we are
given the length of all three sides we
can use the heron's formula which is
learnt and to use the heron's formula
the first thing we need to find is the
semi perimeter of this triangle it will
be 5 plus 12 plus 13 divided by 2 that
will be 30 by 2 which equals 15 15 is
the semi perimeter of this triangle so
what will be the area it will be the
square root of Sammy perimeter which is
15 times semi-perimeter minus 5 times
semi-perimeter minus 12 times
semi-perimeter minus 13 it will be the
square root of 15 times 10 times 3 times
2 writing this in terms of its prime
factors gives us this expression solving
it further we get its area as 30 squared
units that's how we can use the heron's
formula to find the area of a triangle
but wait look at the numbers again do
they ring a bell 5 12 and 13 form a
Pythagorean triple which in turn tells
us that this should be a right triangle
13 being
largest site will be the hypotenuse and
this will be the right angle so tell me
did we really have to do all this not
really we could just use the 1/2 base
times height formula and get the answer
as 30 square units I can't say it enough
in your competitive exams time is of
utmost importance
getting the correct answer matters yes
but how quickly you arrive at it is what
makes the difference
you